schön dass ihr da seid jetzt erzählt uns
erst mal ganz kurz jeder für sich ihr
habt unglaublich viel abgenommen
ganz kurz die geschichte saskia funck du
doch mal an ja ich habe 96 kilo in 18
monaten verloren und das war eine ganz
einfache methode nämlich meine kalorien
zu zählen und lebt von einer app meine
lebensmittel abzuwiegen wir überhaupt
wieder ein bewusstsein für ernährung zu
schaffen und einem jahr ungefähr halte
ich jetzt mein gewicht wahnsinn und
burak wie ist das bei dir auch genauso
kurz bitte ich habe den drei bis vier
jahren habe ich unter klingt wieder
abgenommen und das ganze mit mindset
sport und ernährung und ich halt mein
gewicht potts nürnberger laden den ich
betreibe und alles gut
wahnsinn das bild gerade kurz stehen
geblieben ich habe jetzt sehe ich euch
beide wieder wunderbar gott sei dank
was haltet ihr denn gegenseitig von der
leistung des anderen das verbindet euch
doch jetzt oder saskia was was denkst du
über burak ja klasse leistung auf jeden
fall ich denke wir beide wissen einfach
beide ganz genau was der andere
durchgemacht hat wie das leben vorjahr
war wie es jetzt ist was sich geändert
hat und ob wir uns kennengelernt haben
ein paar wochen ich glaube waren relativ
schnell auf einer wellenlänge weil wir
ganz gut connecten bei mir halt einfach
einen ähnlichen weg gegangen sind ja und
ich hab natürlich dem respekt den ich
vor mir selber auch habe den habe ich
natürlich auch wo ihm buback gibt es
etwas was wir wissen müssen über saskia
witzel stolz auf sie
das portal das ist so krass wenn leute
wir haben letztens darüber gesprochen
wenn du so nah an jemanden wir uns ja
eigentlich fast denselben weg
durchlaufen hat wie du natürlich so auch
auf seine art und weise ist aber so
krass wie wohnen so nah aneinander und
mussten von uns eigentlich gar nicht
haben beide den selben weg nicht durch
gaskraft mittel
ich finds auch richtig krass also ihr
zwei ihr seid krass wahnsinn was ihr da
geschafft habe selbst wenn man nur ein
paar kilo zuviel hatte weiß jeder wie
schwer es ist abzunehmen
deshalb eine frage wirklich an alle was
ist absoluter geheimtipp wie kann ich
abnehmen intrinsische motivation du
musst einfach aus dem haus selber das
absolut wollen und wenn du das einmal
begriffen hast dass du was ändern muss
dass du für immer was ändern musste dann
funktioniert ist eigentlich fast wie von
alleine kann es auf jeden fall so
unterschreiben also ich glaube wenn du
etwas findest woran du spaß hast und
wenn du dein tag wirklich danach
ausrichten ist und jeden tag schon
einfach guten laune aufstehst oder nicht
einfach darum kümmert dass du diese gute
laune macht und dein leben schön machst
das ist schon der erste schritt und und
der rest kommt dann von alleine
du kriegst er bock drauf einfach auch
das ist so ein schönes leben haft also
es geht um den kopf sagt er es geht um
das mindset dann kann man abnehmen was
uns jetzt noch wirklich interessiert
werdet ihr in kontakt bleiben mehr 2
die zukunft aus gibt es ein kleiner
ausblick darf ich mal sagen was sie ja
klar
ja also sagt ja und ich haben vor
zusammen videopodcast in zukunft zu
machen gerade mit unseren themen und
genau willst du noch was ergänzen
ergänzt muss doch ja ich denke also dass
auch wir immer wieder gefragt ist unser
weg früher wie leben wir jetzt was was
machen wir jetzt anders und das ist
einfach den leuten mitteilen und auf
eine gute art und weise
wir ergänzen uns glaube ich auch ganz
gut er so ein bisschen er als lockere
ich oftmals ein bisschen so lockt das
holt viele leute ab und holt uns da
april vor drei jahren bestanden
das hat sich wirklich coole an ihrem
macht echt was draus und wer euch noch
näher kennenlernen will der kann das bei
uns auf bild.de tun ab morgen gibt es
eure doku nämlich zu sehen ich sage es
nochmal herzlichen glückwunsch an euch
zwar großes geleistet und wir wünschen
euch alle alles gute mehr nachrichten
und breaking news nur bei bild schaut
euch hier das nächste video an und
vergessen nicht zu abonnieren